hello
my name is i'm the cso for
scribe biosciences the title of my talk
today is
micro environment on demand a
breakthrough technology for personal
lifestyle therapy discoveries
scribe bio was uh spun out of the
abating labs at ucsf
um and the technology that we use is a
proprietary dropper microfluidic
platform
for the precise construction of a single
cell co-culture assays
for high throughput cell cell retraction
analysis and
linking those those those functional
interactors
to single cell sequencing we've had
three publications so far
and our core technology has been awarded
a u.s patent
for the talk outline i have two uh uh
broad segments uh the first part of the
talk i'll focus on the importance of
some cell interactions
uh specifically at a bison level what i
mean by by cell is
typically a center cell and a receiver
cell present in the same reaction
or control cell numbers meaning you know
having five cells of one type and one
cell of another type
though i would not focus too much on
that in the stock and there are benefits
to doing the
single cell functional analysis methods
you know uh you know inaudible cells
that matter
and how that's done is what i will talk
about in this in this presentation
and there are many applications that one
could um
one could uh utilize this technology for
screening for tumor and
human new antigens and cognitive t cells
um gamma delta t cells demma delta keys
for cars
screening for for for those for those
kinds of molecules
uh and then finally copy cell variant
screens which is what i would focus my
talk on
um this is a general purpose technology
uh and anytime you want to study
a standard cell and a receiver cell
interacting with one another
and then link them uh to single cell
genomics this is a
this would this will be an ideal
technology to do that um
so and then the second part of the
technology a second part of the talk
i'll focus on
scribe bios micro environment on demand
technology i'll talk about the workflow
and then the data that we've obtained
using uh a healthy donor car t
cells so cartes are hybrid molecules
uh that are formed from uh varied from
the variable regions
of antibodies
which are linked uh to form a single
chain and
fused to uh t cell co-stimulated domains
and activation domains
and cortisol therapy has been shown to
be effective for certain blood blood
cancers
and and and there has been a lot of
interest in deploying car t-cell therapy
for solid tumors as well
and the and the and the main reason for
that is they are they are actually
independent
and so do not require uh the need for
antigen presentation
however side you know side effects exist
for parties
including cytokine release syndrome and
neurotoxicity events
and so the field has been working on how
to obtain an optimal car
and so the need for costly functional
screens
starts uh to become a reality when you
when you know when you when you want to
deploy this kind of a technology
this kind of a a therapy to multiple uh
cancers and there is no good way to do
this today
so i've presented a use case here where
if you want to screen 200 000
uh scfp variants and find what
an optimal car variant how do you go
about doing it and what is optimal
you know for example do you want you
know you want to check for chronic
signaling
you want to look for cell killing
efficiency you may
you may be interested in understanding
gene expression differences between
optimal and sub-optimal cars and how
they contribute to side effects
and these kinds of projects are already
ongoing where i show the evidence in the
form of a paper
published in 2013 where 150 000 scfe
variants
uh where at a hundred actually receiver
screen
and so this means that you have to
screen 50 over 15 million
uh cells which means it requires a
tremendous amount of throughput
and doing this in a bulk assay uh you
know you have to do it in a serial
fashion
in addition to scfe variants uh um there
are
there is tremendous interest in
understanding other uh properties of
cartes such as cocky persistence
in in in cancer patients and and to
understand and and
improve the uh persistence of carties uh
co-stability domains have been have been
uh swapped into the into the into the
cars
uh to figure out which cars um um
persist in patients for a long time and
obviously one could
imagine uh combining the two efforts to
do
to screen for uh optimal car variants
that have multiple properties and the
way it's done as i said earlier
is through bulk assays that thousands of
car variants are interrogated at a
single time
and then and then in a serial fashion
you you you
understand which variant it is um
but this is uh much easier done using
single cell functional assays
provided you have the throughput in the
hundreds of thousands to millions
and also have the ability to integrate
the
the functional asset to sequencing where
you can readily obtain obtain the
variance sequence information
that truly matter so at a single cell
level uh people would want to measure
uh cytokine responses uh track diesel
activation signatures or ask themselves
that
and these kinds of activities can be
performed using facts as well
because you can start a sender cell and
a receiver cell into the same reaction
vessel
however facts based technologies short
uh into 96 well or 384 well plates which
utilize larger volumes meaning
microliter size volumes and simple cell
secretions
are at a very low concentration that's
reserved you do not have a sensitivity
to uh to um to you know to assess
uh single cell assays and so and then i
say you know refer to earlier once you
uh know uh which
which variant functionally is is is is
critical
you can take that and you know you
should be able to sequence that and so
um you start you know the this kind of a
a
streamlined technology workflow can help
you
uh um start from a large uh number of
variants and end up with
hundreds to thousands of variants that
you can further uh study
uh to do you know to to
for optimal properties
and so typically these kinds of studies
if you want the kind of throughput that
we're talking about
are done using uh droplets or nanowells
and so when you want to do this with
droppers you start with patient t cells
target cells and amino acids
and uh randomly load the molecular
droplets when you do
a random loading it's governed by for
poisson distribution
and it comes with it as many
inefficiencies and so the
the um the assembly that you're really
interested in which is
a single visa patient t cell and a
target cell and an
amino acid happens very infrequently
and this is shown in a in a publication
uh
where uh using randomly loaded bells
where someone's get a single cell and
otherwise get
you know six or eight cells so uh
what you really want to do is to take
the t-cell library
target cells and immune savings and of
course randomly load them onto single
cell properties
but then grow them in limiting dilution
such that only one droplet out of 10 or
15 contain a cell or a b
and then if those cells and beads are
fluorescently labeled then you can sort
them and then deterministically combine
them
into into into a single assay droplet
and then
and then make millions of identical
replicas to do
that will enable you to perform these
these massive screens
and the workflow for mod that enables
you to do that as shown on this slide
so we'll start with uh uh an input
mixture
where uh you know you have the
individual cells that are fluorescently
labeled encapsulated in droplets
and then you flow these droplets um uh
into a microfluidic channel
where it's uh where it's uh interrogated
by laser excitation
so say uh um the infinite droplet is
detected
uh the droplet is diverted into the
bottom channel and retained in a
dielectrophoretic trap
shown by the two um
dark squares linked by a line let's say
that the first
droplet contained an immune cell that
got retained in the in
diverted into the bottom channel and
merged with in the
in the in the dielectrophobic trap and
retained and once
the the assembly of a single uh immune
cell a single target cylinder uh
under a target b uh or a assay
is encapsulated in a droplet it gets
released and it gets collected
and and you can collect millions of this
in a tube
and then incubate them for uh immune
cell activation so
when an immune cell is activated secret
cytokines
and the acid contains primary antibodies
for up
for specific cytokines that can be
detected and and once
uh the the immune system activation is
completed you have two
options uh to perform already sequencing
the top option shows you uh a
sequencing using third-party devices and
the bottom option would
be using the scribe bio workflow so
let's first talk about the top option
and i'm going to show you data only for
the top option today
uh so the top the workflow on the top
shows
uh you know the same kind of sorting
mechanism that i talked about earlier
but instead this time we are going to
sort based on the
as a positive signal that resulted from
the immune cell activation
and so you could collect the heads and
then feed it into the 10x genomic system
or
other third-party device um
when you do this you know you lose the
linkage between
the center cell and the receiver cell
and because when you sequence them using
the 10x genomic system
they're all sequenced as single cells
but you know and
but the link between the two uh cells
that uh
that resulted in the immune cell
activation is lost
but if you want to preserve the linkage
then uh
we are working on a method where we have
droplets
that contain um dna barcode beads
uh so each doppler will contain a single
dna markov and b
along with lysis and rt reagents that
can be flowed through the microfluidic
channel
and then using the same mechanism that i
mentioned earlier
can be merged in the dielectrophoretic
trap
and collected and then and then you can
perform a
reverse transport based reaction to
generate the cdna
by doing this method you can you know
because each dropper contains a single
mark or a b
the information between the center cell
and the receiver cell
is coded or by the same barcode and so
this would be
important for understanding say a new
antigen uh which neuroscience paired
with which t cell receptor
so in addition to performing uh um
eventual activation assays and thinking
that the symbols of genomics
using collector droppers we can also
arrange image these droplets
uh and and that can be used for temporal
studies
um so to summarize the unique features
of this technology
we can perform precision cell
combination combinations
selectively high throughput selective
high throughput symbols and rna
sequencing
that's scalable one million
deterministic assemblies we can assemble
cells and reagents as long as they are
fluorescently labeled we can assemble
them
deterministically and finally we can
array and perform temporal studies
so the next couple of slides i'm going
to talk about i'm going to show you
data to support the individual parts of
the workflow the first
part of the workflow is droplet merging
and so for that
we asked the question if we had a
droplet that contained a red bee
and a dropper that contained a bluebee
how accurately can we
uh merge them and then and then and then
get the droplets to have a red and a
blue bead in the same problem
and the results of that experiment is
shown here where
we have a 104 droppers of the
image uh under a microscope and we
manually counted to
see how many of those droplets contain a
single
red beam and a single blue bead and we
found that 93 of the out of 104 droplets
contained a single red bead and a single
movie
if you observe the there are there are a
couple of uh uh
scenarios where um um where you have uh
three uh three beads in the same dropper
coming from a a 2-b droplet
from the start from the initial stay in
the initial starting point
so so those are essentially
they are not artifacts of the merging
technology but rather
uh in the starting emulsion we had uh
some droplets that contain
more than one bead or two beads or two
red beads or two blue beads
that got merged uh and so you you know
we just
resulted in a 3b droplet so if you
consider that as well as not an artifact
of
droplet merging then our droplet merging
accuracy is uh is is greater than 95
and the two negatives are shown
highlighted by the red rectangles
and and the the the image shows the
assembled acid droplets where
the droplets contain uh a red bead and
the blue beam
uh as we discussed earlier and finally
uh
you know i'm showing cells that were
labeled with three different
fluorophores deterministically
uh brought together in droplets we can
see that uh it's at a very high
rectangular so that we can
bring together uh three
uh uh three cell types in the same
droplet
so the second part of the workflow is
direct washery elisa and for that
uh what we do is to have a tumor cell
and an immune cell as well as a bead
bond primary antibody for
cytokines as well as dye label secondary
antibody
encapsulated in the assembled problem
and if uh immune cell targets
star talks to a target cell it will
secrete certain cytokines
and those cytokines can be captured on
the onto the
uh under the bead bound primary antibody
which
would enable the dye level secondary
antibody dispersed through the entire
droplet to coalesce onto the bead uh
producing a focused area of fluorescence
so i want to point out that the total
amount of fluorescence in these
uh droplets are the same whatever that's
present on
in the in the dispersed solution gets
coalesced onto the ba
and so in this slide shows some evidence
for
for uh uh for for the for the washery
elisa
so what we've done here is to
encapsulate different
uh amounts of uh il2 protein in the
droplets
and then perform the washer elisa method
that i
described from the previous slide you
can see that at 0.1 nanomolar you can
barely see the bead
bead bound in fluorescent
however at one another and five
nanomolar the b bond fluorescence is
very
uh um uh obvious and so so we think that
uh that that the the dynamic range for
this
uh for the system is anywhere from half
a nanomolar to five nanomolar
and that is well within the regime of uh
what single cells secrete
for concentrations of cytokines in
the volumes that prevail in these
products um
and then and then uh in the last uh
the far right i showed the same assay
with four molester activated pbmcs
so in addition to cytokine secretions we
can also measure cell death and i'm
showing
an example here where we tried to
measure cell death and cytokine
secretion
uh in the same uh acid droplet
so for this experiment which was done in
the early days of technology development
uh one of the first experiments that we
did actually
is so as a result we did not label the
khaki and raji styles we didn't have
enough
lasers to to detect all the different
entities that that could be for simply
labeled in this experiment
so we used karthi and raja cells
unlabeled
we poison encapsulated them
anti-interferon gamma beads are
blue in color and you can see that in
some of the some of the emotions
um if cartisol secreted from gamma the
anti-from gamma beads that are blue turn
magenta
color and if you look into the figure
every rocker that contains a magenta
color b also contains a
uh green cell indicative of sight of
screen update
and suggesting that the the cells are uh
doubt
or dead um in addition to
performing cell death secretion assays
we can also
uh uh encapsulate different numbers of
target cells
uh with the karti cells so here i show
uh one carti cell
uh paired with either uh one target cell
or two target cells or three target
cells and you can see that uh that the
the the single cartile cells cell is
engaging with three up to three
target cells and forming an immune nice
immune synapse
and so several research questions can be
asked using this technology
uh ability to study cardi exhaustion for
example
if i encapsulate 10 uh cocktail cells
sorry ten uh rajiv cells in the presence
of one copy cell
do all of them get killed so those kinds
of questions can be answered
cooperative cell thinning understanding
cooperative cycling character and
interactions
temporal nature of cytosis versus
interferon gamma situations
tonic signaling these kinds of
functional
characteristics can be assessed and then
they can be coupled with simple cell
genomics to
understand phenotypically how
the different cells are different and
that workflow integration is what i'm
going to talk about in the latter half
of my talk
um where we're going to uh i'm going to
show you data
for how we functionalized how we
integrated functional sorting with
solution and bdj sequencing
using healthy donor cartilage and so for
this
experiment we started with alpha cd19
car t cells
prepared using t cells from two healthy
donors carti cells and rajya cells were
assembled one to one
and merged with interferon gamma acid
reagents and droplets
uh 20 000 assembled droplets were
collected in one and a half hours
and incubated for 12 hours at 37 degrees
and the acid droplets were sorted for
interferon gamma sigma
and 2000 profits were collected and the
droplets were de-emulsified
and single cells were collected by
ability measured the viability was
greater than 90
after this process and subjected to
single cell rna sequencing in pcr
for data analysis uh we did graph-based
clustering
and then and then uh using the clusters
obtained from the gene expression data
we projected them uh on the newmark
plots uh we computed poly functional
gene expression signatures as well as
carting
logistical signatures as well as looking
at
the checkpoint blockade gene expression
i'm showing results from one healthy
donor but
the other healthy lunar the results will
be used
so for expectations i want to just make
sure that
the you know what to expect from this
data so hits our sequence of single
cells because
the for the for the single cell
sequencing we use the 10x genomic system
and
as as i mentioned previously
when you put the cells assembled
assemblies into the tennessee normal
system they are
all going to be sequenced as single
cells the stored population was not
washed
to prevent loss of pressure single cells
and the salt population is also expected
to contain some non hints as well
due to sub-optimal sorting gait
selection
so target cells and cartilage cells are
expected to get different cell barcodes
and so
they they are expected to be in separate
clusters but if target and carty cells
are dominant
as as i showed you know
like formation of an immune synapse that
i showed previously
they will share a barcode between
they're expected to share a barcode
between pcr sleek
and rnsc so
this slide shows the gene expression
data that we obtained
uh uh from from from our efforts uh the
the left-hand side shows the gene
expression and right-hand side shows vdj
uh uh sequence information overlaid on
top of the gene expression data
the humor blocks new map plots were
derived from seven groups of clusters
identified by graph based
clustering even though you see seven
groups of clusters
it's uh what i what what is obvious is
there are two
large subpopulations of cells here in
this in this
uh in this uh in this emap block so what
are those clusters
so we try to do uh deeper into that
and so for the first question that we
asked was where are the bhaji cell
markers
and when you look for the rajya cell
markers they are enriched in one of the
subpopulations of
the cartes and and and when you
drill further down into the data you see
that 97
of the cells in these clusters shared
barcodes between bdj
and the rajiv markers and so this
suggests that potentially these are
rajit
doublets that happen due to an immune
synapse
event the next question that we asked
was
um what about checkpoint blockade genes
and so when you look for checkpoint
blocking genes that are highlighted in
blue color
in the in the in the top uh in the right
hand side of
the path of the slide panel uh you see
that they're all
enriched for you know checkpoint bucket
genes are enriched
in in a couple of clusters on the other
sub-population
uh that is not uh common to
the rajasthan market and that i thought
was interesting and so when we looked
into the data
uh more deeply he thought he found that
71
of the cells with bdj barcodes and
clusters 4 and 6
expressed at point block 18 and finally
the cartesian clusters 2 and uh shown uh
you know
uh uh here uh appeared to be a separate
third group
and was unremarkable so it was really
interesting to see
uh uh you know two subpopulations of
car t cells one subpopulation um uh
aligning with rajy's cell barcodes uh
and then other population
uh expressing uh uh checkpoint blockade
genes
and not in common with not a whole lot
in common with
uh the rajis um so
so we next we asked a question what
about poly functionality
uh how poly functional are these are
these copy cells
because highly poly functional t cells
within cartisal products have been
associated with chemical response
so we wanted to understand whether the
cytotoxic
uh cartes are also highly poly
functional
and poly functionalities determine is
defined by a
t cell any t-cell that expresses uh more
than two cytokines
and and when you look at the the
cytotoxic copies that we saw here
they uh they had they showed low quality
functionality
and not high quality functionality um
and and
and and what was also interesting was
the the the uh
um the uh the clusters that uh showed
enrichment of checkpoint blockade genes
show high quality functionality so to
summarize
uh i've shown some data to to
that that integrates single cell core
cultural assets with single cell rna
sequencing
and vdj sequencing uh interferon gamma
assay based sorting results in
enrichment of poly functional t cells
and there appears to be three distinct
populations of copies
um there's a raji associated cartoon
that may be psychotoxic
and show low quality functionality there
are highly poly functional parties that
also show
expression of checkpoint blockade genes
uh indicative of
diesel exhaustion uh just uh remember
that these copies were sorted based on
interferon demo sorting so
um you know are they what why
why were they started based on that
signature something that we want to
understand better
and then finally there are carti cells
in clusters two and three that are
unremarkable
and these results were reproduced using
uh uh carti cells from the other one
and finally i want to acknowledge uh the
scrap bio team for the hard work
they pulled off a lot of data in a very
short period of time
i'm extremely thankful for their hard
work and then of course
the embargo lab for the continued
support camera
engine bioengineering for providing us
with the cocky cells from healthy donors
and our seed investors darpa nih and nsf
for continued support in the form of
funding thank you very much for
listening